5 qui a signé cette lettre demandant aux
autorités d'imposer le masque dans les
transports en commun dr caroline couach
c'est justement avec nous ce soir je
rappelle pour les uns vous êtes pédiatre
microbiologistes infectiologues et
épidémiologistes osu sainte-justine
bonsoir dr couach on se demande à mme
denis on va revenir un peu sur
l'actualité du jour parce que les
autorités la santé publique fédérale
s'attendent à une deuxième vague
aussitôt que dans quelques semaines si
on relâche toutes les mesures de
prévention est ce que vous avez les
mêmes craintes parce qu on était quand
même on on a quand même insisté sur le
fait que la coc vide ça peut revenir en
force très rapidement oui en fait je
pense qu'on regarde tout ce qui est en
train de se passer aux états unis avec
le relâchement et la distanciation
physique et l'ouverture de à peu près
tous les milieux qui on voit que l'écho
monte très rapidement et donc par
analogie on se dit que si on fait la
même chose ici c'est très possible que
ça survienne
les autorités fédérale affirme aussi bon
que l'épidémie est contrôlée mais en
même temps dr arruda dit aujourd'hui
quand on déconfinement le pire danger
c'est d'oublier les mesures de
prévention est l'une des choses qui a
attiré mon attention dans les faits
saillants présenté aujourd'hui par la
santé publique du canada
c'est ce qui se passe chez les jeunes en
augmentation de la transmission chez les
jeunes de 20 à 39 ans vous parlez de ce
qui se passe aux etats unis est ce que
c'est une donnée cap sur votre attention
les jeunes
oui parce qu'en fait c'est arrivé aux
etats unis c'est exactement ça c'est
avec l'ouverture des bars avec les
recrutements qui ont été permis c'est
surtout la tranche des 20 39 ans qui ont
profité de ces de ces rassemblements là
et c'est donc dans ce groupe là que ça
se transmet en même temps on le sait que
ces jeunes là sont moins à risque de
complications le problème c'est comme
ils peuvent être asymptomatique et
peuvent croiser dans leur vie des gens
qui sont à risque de complications c'est
là où le bât blesse c'est quand on
regarde en fait qui se passe est exact
les soins intensifs sont plaint déjà
alors que la majorité des cas semble
être quand même mais chez les plus
jeunes le premier ministre le
gouvernance et
demain le port du masque obligatoire et
transports en commun est ce que vous
êtes soulagé parce que vous avez
vraiment pris position en faveur de
cette orientation losc ça vous soulage
c'est une c'est une très bonne nouvelle
je pense que les transports en commun
sont l'endroit où on est le plus amer
d'être collé les vins sur d autres sens
très bonne ventilation sont par exemple
dans le métro est donc de porter un
masque on couvre visage ça permet aux
personnes qui potentiellement pourrait
être infectieuses de garder leur
gouttelettes infectieuses cours il est
donc c'est un premier très bon pas il va
falloir voir maintenant s'il faut pas
aussi imposer cette règle leur pour tout
ce qui est en droit public intérieur
parce que vous savez y des des gens qui
sont anti masquant et même des gens qui
pensent que le virus est grandement
exagérée par nous les médias est ce que
vous pensez qu'une mesure comme celle là
quand le gouvernement dit à partir de
maintenant le masque est obligatoire
dans le transport en commun ça donne une
légitimité ce à peu normalisée le port
du masque
je pense que oui ça peut aussi permettra
pas justement aux sociétés de transport
de dire écoutez on vous demande de
porter le masque
en voici un un peu comme le quand le
port de la ceinture de sécurité est
devenue obligatoire
c'est à ce moment là que les gens ce
sont bien les fortes et puis maintenant
l'étape tue on se pose même plus la
question
on rentre dans la voiture puis ont la
tâche je pense qu'éventuellement on va
prendre l'habitude de porter de masque
et vaincus on espère qu'un jour on en
aura plus besoin nommé pendant les
prochains mois ça va devenir de plus en
plus normal d'en avoir
je veux que vous nous parler de cette
étude chinoise qui a été publiée dans la
revue nature qui conclut qu'il est
porteurs asymptomatiques ont peu ou pas
d'anticorps quelques semaines après
avoir été infectés il serait donc moins
immunisés que les gens qui ont été très
très malade
c'est surprenant et inquiétant qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
c'est pas la première étude qui nous
démontre ça ça fait déjà quelques temps
qu'on cite les personnes qui ont moins
de symptômes ont moins d'anticorps que
celles qui sont très malades
maintenant c'est la première étude qui
compare vraiment différent gros coup
verizon comparaissaient avec lui un
groupe de gens qui avaient des symptômes
légers
un autre groupe de gens qui étaient pcr
négatif donc c'est intéressant de voir
est-ce que la seule chose qu'on sait pas
vraiment jusqu'à maintenant c'est à quel
niveau d'anticorps on a besoin pour être
protégés et est ce que les anticorps
sont la seule portion de notre des
militaires qui nous protège parce qu'on
a aussi une immunité cellulaire qui peut
jouer un rôle
donc à les regarder comme ça on dirait
que les personnes asymptomatiques sont
moins bien protégés mais je pense que
c'est le temps qui nous dira avec
d'autres études à savoir si vraiment le
risque devient infection est plus grand
chez ces gens là où en fait s'il existe
un risque d'infection je voudrais que on
le sait pas encore là c'est vraiment des
études qui doivent être faites
cette même étude avance aussi que 70 %
des porteurs asymptomatiques qui avait
des anomalies pulmonaire qu'est ce
qu'est ce que vous faites de cette
donnée que ça veut dire que le virus
était vraiment leur qui s'est multiplié
mais que pour une raison x le système
immunitaire du patient en question n'a
pas réagi assez fortement pour donner
des symptômes mais sexy c'est une
trouvaille qui était très intéressante
ça avait été rapportée aussi quand il
avait su gagner les poumons de personnes
asymptomatiques sur le domaine plus mais
à l'époque comme ceux des personnes plus
âgées on n'était pas capable de dire est
ce que ces anomalies étaient là avant
lorsque s'il semble effectivement que
les personnes qui ont du virus au niveau
des voies respiratoires sans symptômes
ont quand même le virus a quand même été
capable de produire quelques méfaits bon
mais docteur couach on vous remercie
beaucoup de votre éclairage merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci bonne soirée